Coffee on a Tuesday and blog 26.
I'm back,
baby.
In the spring of 18,
18,
the poet John Keats wrote a letter to
his friend John Hamilton Reynolds,
which contained in it a poetic metaphor
for how he saw human life.
He called it the mansion of many
apartments and the image goes sort of
like this.
The first department we step into,
he calls the thoughtless chamber here.
We remain for as long as we do not think
now,
I think keats means by this thinking
deeply,
philosophically,
poetically,
et Cetera,
and the whole time we're in this
chamber,
this apartment,
the door to the next department is wide
open,
showing a bright appearance on the other
side.
Now at first,
maybe we have no motivation to move
toward it,
but slowly,
eventually the thinking principle impels
us to and we go in.
Now,
once we get inside into the second
chamber,
which keeps calls,
the Chamber of maiden thought we become
intoxicated by the light and atmosphere.
We see nothing but pleasant wonders and
think of the laying there forever in
delight.
In other words,
we get a taste of the ideal.
Then the mood changes,
one of the effects of sharpening one's
mind and the Chamber of maiden thought
is that one begins to see deeper into
the heart of man,
into the misery,
pain,
sickness and depression,
that the world is full of.
These things gradually begin to darken
the chamber,
fill it with the fog,
but at the same time that it gets dark
on all sides of the room,
doors are set open leading away to dark
passages,
which it then becomes one's choice to
take or not take.
You can see that even in a letter,
keats's powers of description are
extraordinary.
He later coined the term negative
capability,
a concept to describe an artist who
understanding the inherent mysteries of
life could find the strength to remain
to be in uncertainties,
mysteries,
doubts without any irritable reaching
after fact and reason.
He cited Shakespeare as a key example of
an artist who had achieved this in 1890
a year.
After the letter to John Reynolds,
keats writes his own to a nightingale,
one of his best works.
Indeed,
one of the best works of poetry,
in my opinion,
eight stands as long the poem tells of
the narrators reaction to hearing the
song of a nightingale to bird being
representative of the ideal and his
profound longing to join it even at the
expense of his life.
The poem starts with the narrator
becoming paralyzed by the bird song,
which commences a journey through the
layers of his soul.
Now,
in a minute,
I'm just going to put a link up here
probably right here to another video
where all recite the poem for you
because poems like this should be heard.
And in the corner somewhere in one of
these corners,
I'm going to put numbers corresponding
to the stanza so that you'll have a sign
posts,
um,
as,
as we go along,
try to keep in mind the metaphor of the
management of many apartments and the
concept of negative capability.
While I'm reading it.
Also,
it might be worthwhile to say that the
general rule with art is that you could
have any feeling about it that you damn
well please,
but whatever you like,
whatever you know you fancy in terms of
art,
it's good to memorize poems I highly
recommended,
and if you want to memorize one of your
favorite poems and recite it and posted
as a rated video response,
I will most certainly put it up on the
video so
the link should be there.
Now,
maybe here,
I don't know.
Clicked.
Click on it.
Oh,
to a nightingale like John Keats.
Click here,
right here,
right here.
My face is now the lake.
It's a good poem.
I promise.
You have to believe me.
Please.
Believe me.
You
clicked yet.